les orléanais se souviennent peut être
de ces petits caractères apparu sur les
panneaux de la ville en 2012 c'était
pour annoncer le premier festival hors
les anneaux id
désormais il s'est installé dans le
paysage de la ville et prend ses
quartiers dans un lieu improbable la
collégiale saint-pierre le prix est lié
cet édifice roman du 12e siècle fait
partie des lieux qui accueillent des
créations à la pointe de la technologie
technologique peut-être un peu trop
présent dans nos vies
interrogation oui elle existe elle est
peut-être pas assez vivace a bon goût et
du coup c'est aussi l'occasion à travers
un festival tel corps les anneaux inc de
mettre un petit peu sur la place
publique ses questionnements proposer un
certain nombre voilà deux problématiques
et aussi de bonheur à venir grâce à ces
outils numériques exemple pied de nez au
smartphone ou autre ordinateur
voici un réseau qui fonctionne à l'eau
un message étape et puis codé en morse
grâce à des bulles avant d'être lus par
une autre machine
l'idée c'est de se dire pourquoi aller
si vite pour aller plus vite toujours
plus vite
en fait ce qui est important c'est de
saveur
ans mais comme messager vaut mieux
transmettre des petits messages courts
et bien pensé que de la bouillie en
temps réel c'est notre motion des
créations qui incite à la réflexion
nouveauté le festival devient une
biennale et prend de l'ampleur
il se déroule sur une vingtaine de lieux
différents dans toute la ville terminus
le 15 février prochain